well i got to tell you i'm i'm not tired
of winning yet i'm really not we i'm
sure you've heard the news by now the
supreme court passed down their decision
and they have effectively killed the
biden's illegal unconstitutional vaccine
mandate uh it's blocked it's done the
daily wire we were the first company in
the nation to file suit against it we
were first in line to fight this thing
and uh and we won and you know why did
we win well because um the
the vaccine mandate was
blatantly unconstitutional and on top of
that it also didn't make any scientific
sense because uh vaccine vaccinated
people can still spread the virus so it
was illegal illogical and immoral and it
absolutely deserved to die a fiery death
which it effectively has done now um so
this is what we do the daily wire we
fight back and we win and that's why we
want to thank our members for being a
part of this you were really on the team
and you helped this happen this is your
win as well if you're not a member yet
and you want to be a part of the winning
team and you want to be part of this of
this of this you know of this fight
because there's a lot more fighting left
to be done then you can become a member
today um go to dailywire.com become a
member and for one day this is just the
one day we're doing it we're giving 40
off with very appropriately code winning
that's 40 off code winning
just today to become a member and join
the fight